welcome back to rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse in with Black Widow as the next
MCU installment one weird detail from
the Black Widow footage has been
haunting me with the notion that this
film won't be nearly as straightforward
as the Jason Bourne II trailers have
suggested specifically there is this
shot of de Tasha Romanov meeting with
Yelena biloba and in Natasha's hand is
something red has it been the hands on
that [ __ ] and they appear to be some
things red and many have suggested that
these look a lot like him particles
which allow access to the quantum realm
time vortexes and time travel by
shrinking now we have been told that
Black Widow will be set in the years
between Captain America's Civil War and
Avengers infinity war roughly 2016 to
2018 when Natasha was on the run
following her treasonous decision to
join team cap in their defiance of the
US government and secretary Ross but the
Black Widow footage has also leaked some
tricky clues when it comes to the time
period like the first trailer showed
Ross but William Hurt was clearly
de-aged with that silver fox fur he's
had since the Incredible Hulk which was
set in the mid to late 2000s now
rendered blonde hurts hair color back in
the 80s and early 90s so when the hell
is this movie really taking place could
the answer to this question really
involve war time travel but after
endgame do we really want more time
travel well what if I told you it could
be done in a grounded very emotional
pneumatic way one that would actually
make you love this movie and MCU even
more and what if I told you that this
theory could reveal to us the true
identity of taskmaster well I got that
theory and it's about to get explained
okay let's rewind the clock to Avengers
in game now I'm sorry to revisit in game
4 the I love you three thousandth time
but this theory just requires us to
re-examine the movies timeline so bear
with me okay remember that each Avenger
was given exactly two Pym particles one
to jump back to their destination Year
in the past and one more to return after
they had acquired their target infinity
stone stark and cap failed to steal the
space stone and their first go so they
had to use their second Pym particles to
jump even further back to a time and
place that they could get more Pym
particles for their return trip which
brought them to camp Lehi in 1970 and
that scene cat snatched for Pym particle
vials but he leaves exactly seven vials
and PIMs case interestingly that handful
of red some things that natasha has
holding a black widow
looks to be a
well six or seven of them so when
Natasha died on Vermeer that death was
final it was the blood price required
for the soul stone unlike the other
stone soul stone has some divine curse
attached to it perhaps from these
Celestials themselves of the death that
you have to pay for it is irreversible
so if Natasha were to somehow survive
that fall or to cheat death
there's no way Clint could have brought
the soul stone back to the present day
for banner and start to bring everyone
back and kill thanos so she's dead
but right before she died Natasha still
possessed one unused Pym particle during
that fall so let's just say that in
those brief seconds as she fell natasha
gets an idea now she has accepted her
fate she's ready to trade her soul for
the soul stone but she still has this
unused Pym particle in her packet and
she thinks oh things I still could do
with smack too late she hits the ground
blip but let's say back during the poll
natasha realizes that she has some
unfinished business now she actually has
a way to clear some of the red in her
ledger and she remembers her visit with
cap to camp Lehi and kept America Winter
Soldier remember that and she remembers
the classified shield Hydra documents
that she dumped on the web and recalling
hank pym x' shield lab at Lehigh in 1970
she activates her one Romanian Pym
particle zips through the quantum tunnel
and arrives at Hank Pym slab moments
after cap left it and she grabs the
remaining seven vials and jumps ahead in
time a woman on a mission look there's a
lot of details I want to talk about here
and if you watch a lot of newer Xers
videos you know how many different
fictional universes I got to keep
straight up here a big help with keeping
me alert and focused especially after a
long night of rewatch --is and benjin is
bang energy and thanks to them for
sponsoring this video every can of bang
is 16 ounces that's right there's no
wimpy 12 ounce cans here it contains 300
milligrams of caffeine sugar free zero
calories yet it tastes great with over
20 different flavors to choose from one
of those great flavors is a purple whap
air it's like biting into guava and a
pear at the same time like if it
wahpeton a pear had six and they made
this it's like that but an energy drink
form and I'm feeling great ready to
continue with this look they're just
some days where I'm just feeling low I'm
feeling lethargic I can't get through
the next time but as if a bang
10 so I finish the sentence I'm here I'm
back check out banging on Instagram you
can get 25% off your order at Bank
Energy calm when you use the code new
rock stars 25 there you can get a
variety 12-pack with a dozen of their
flavors flavors like pina colada cotton
candy birthday cake bash so if you're
like me and if your friends forget your
birthday every year bang will make you
feel loved thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang energy com using code new rockstars
25 and follow the inventor of bang on
instagram at bang energy dot CEO okay
back to Black Widows mission armed with
a flight of PIM shots
how would natasha romanoff first use
this red to clear her head
well the Black Widow prelude comics have
teased an old name that you might
remember Jim I cough dre cough came up
during Ross's search for Natasha as the
name of the Russian general who oversaw
the Black Widow Red Room program and Dre
Cobb was a lingering mystery from all
the way back in the first Avengers when
Loki used that name to taunts Natasha
for her past sins I got red in my ledger
I'd like to wipe it out Kenny can he
wipe out that much red Dre coughs
daughter Sao Paulo
the hospital fire
Barton told me everything I've always
wondered if Drake Hobbs daughter could
be a rival trainee in the Red Room whom
Natasha killed in order to approve the
extremes she's willing to go but I
killed that she's always been hunted by
so perhaps that first pimp shot will be
to save Drake odds daughter and allow
her Cubs daughter to live in at least
some other alternate timeline
similarly Sal Paulo and the hospital
fire could be two other stops Natasha
makes to write her past lungs and one of
those deaths can be sometime in the mid
90s when Ross would still be a blonde
bombshell and maybe Natasha's read
clearing tour through time will end with
one of her biggest regrets the death of
her longtime rival from the Red Room
Yelena biloba one curious Easter Egg
we've spotted from the Black Widow
footage is that yalena can be seen
wearing the same vest that Natasha shows
up wearing an infinity war perhaps in an
old timeline Natasha took that best
offer rivals corpse but now knowing that
her fate will be sealed on Vermeer
Natasha returns to that past history to
instead save Yelena and allow her sister
figure to live on in a new life and that
brings us to the mystery of taskmaster
in this plot taskmaster and all the
footage we've seen has been completely
masked his identity has been concealed
he could just be revealed as mr.
photographic reflexes Tony masters as he
is in comics or since Marvel has not
announced any big-name actor in the role
is probably gonna be a twist reveal as
someone else in the movie that we
already know my thinking is it's going
to be one of the female characters there
is a line in the trailer okay this guy
yeah that's a setup you could see a mile
away
I'm Pugin taskmaster is a woman with
parallel red-room training Melina Yelena
or as I am now
tinfoil II submitting to you Natasha
Romanov herself that's right I believe
that the final smudger head on the
Tosh's Ledger was a past mission to rid
the world of Red Room assassins to clean
house and try to spare the world from
further soviet-era bloodshed she would
do this under a hooded disguise and
later on Natasha realized that that
liquidation actually liquidated some of
the babies with the bathwater one of
those babies Yelena biloba so now
Natasha having this opportunity to flash
her own life before her eyes uses Pym
particles to return to that past moment
and confront her past deadly self it
proven this reveal would have been great
of our faces the whole time in footage
natasha battles taskmaster on the bridge
their combat moves mirrored exactly
because they're the same person if you
look closely at taskmasters visor the
face that is reflected back
if Natasha's own face widow versus widow
yeah I think we're gonna see Natasha
complete this course correction maybe
with the help of old allies like the red
Guardian to create a new branch reality
in which he Annie Alena can live on in a
new life where they can one day maybe
join the Avengers and with her second
chance completed Natasha will use her
final Pym particle to return to that
fall on war mirror and close the loop
seal her fate and paid the cost of the
soul stone to save the universe
hey comment down below with your
thoughts on this theory follow me at ei
vas following new rock stars on social
media and subscribing the rock stars
here on YouTube sure to hit that
notifications button so you get all of
our Marvel theories and a reminder that
nirach stars offers bonus monthly videos
exclusive to Patriots but the kind of
content YouTube won't really let us
release publicly on the channel like a
frame-by-frame analysis of the church
scene and the King's Men or a breakdown
of the shining you can access all of
that stuff by supporting us on patreon
and a big thank you to all of our
current patrons thanks for watching bye
[Music]